foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
is the Tony Michaels podcast real and
raw political and social commentary the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty you [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of speech
this is the Tony Michaels podcast and
this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
down to the wire
we're getting to the meat and potatoes
folks
Democrats are in the lead don't listen
to the [ __ ] polls I've been telling
this Nate silver is a dumbass
the only dumbass bigger on Twitter than
Nate silver is Elon Musk uh endorsing
Republicans this morning I wonder why he
bought Twitter
I wonder what it could be no I'm just
kidding I know why he bought Twitter
because he's an idiot he didn't really
actually mean to buy Twitter
it's not what he meant to do
and it's clear that he's not capable of
owning a company and running a company
such as Twitter we all knew that he was
a dumb [ __ ]
like anyone who can see through the thin
thin skin of a billionaire can see that
Elon Musk is a dummy
same way you can see that Nate silver
really is a dummy
of course he's great with math if he's
handed the numbers that he has to do
math with
just funny how they both are trying
their best to make their narrative the
way that they want it
it's hilarious I don't know if you
watched uh yesterday it was it was
absolutely
best thing on the internet yesterday
was the Kathy Griffin Scandal where she
she impersonated Elon Musk
which I'm sure we're gonna get in with
with Gabe Sanchez
but the reason why I want to bring up
Elon Musk right now is because he is
endorsing the Republicans on Twitter for
Congress
now he's he's clearly saying I want more
more I want more subsidies
and I want lower taxes
he's clearly saying that and the reason
why he's saying that is because he wants
Joe Biden to be the president I mean in
his tweet he says well there's Democrats
as the President right which he knows
the Democrats are going to give
subsidies for renewable energy and are
going to build infrastructure for
electric cars he's got to have that for
the one side of of his his existence
of his false Legacy of that he invented
electric cars these [ __ ]
these Elon Sins Not only think he's
smart
they think he invented electric cars
it's something else
it's something else
so he has that part of his personality
and part of his existence that he needs
Democrats in power because Republicans
are not going to do any kind of
infrastructure
I mean frankly you put Republicans in
power they might start tearing down
roads and bridges
I I'm dead serious they may start
tearing down roads and bridges so you
can't go certain places
I mean they want to tell you what to do
with your body you don't think they're
going to tell you what to do with your
car
Marjorie Taylor green doesn't know how
batteries work
and she thinks electric cars you know
I guess they're akin to Jewish space
lasers the the
the inherent cousin of them or some [ __ ]
I don't know I can't figure out how she
doesn't understand how batteries work
foreign
but the situation that we're in it right
now in our country
is playing out right on the CEO of of
Twitter's Twitter feed
absolutely 100 percent it's playing out
all you have to do is look and see
that the tail is wagging the dog on the
right
they make no sense they're it's not
supposed to make sense
it's not supposed to be coherent
there's not supposed to be an end goal
in mind ever
literally over the weekend Donald Donald
Trump was was being the CEO of Twitter I
don't know if you noticed that you
remember when he was president he would
tweet out executive policy and executive
orders and the entire government's going
what in the [ __ ] is he doing
that's what Elon Musk was doing this
weekend he was tweeting out terms of
service on the Fly
just just tweeting it out
and everyone's like oh okay well I guess
that's the rule and then he changed the
rule and then it's [ __ ] something
else
but this is the right wing right now and
and to say that that Elon Musk is not
right wing is [ __ ] stupid
he is being wagged around by a bunch of
in-cell right-wingers on the internet
that's how [ __ ] fragile he is he is
so [ __ ] dumb
so [ __ ] dumb that he thinks that the
reason why advertisers have dumped their
budgets
and left Twitter
is because of the woke
activist or some [ __ ]
no it's because they they
don't trust you that that's why dummy
they don't trust you they trusted
Twitter
under the leadership
that was put there
they trusted that
and then you took over and fired all of
them they didn't trust you anymore
especially when you're tweeting terms of
service on the Fly they don't even know
what the social media platform is going
to be next week no clue he doesn't
either by the way
but if the reason why I'm saying this is
because if you give if you go and you
vote or you don't vote
and you give Republicans power this is
literally what is going to play out in
our government
for the next two [ __ ] years
the next two [ __ ] years that's what's
gonna happen
what you have witnessed on Twitter is
the tail wagging the dog that's why
under four years under trump it was like
why is there such craziness
and the reason why is because they have
no principle none
none
that's why I'm so frustrated when people
say Liz Cheney is a hero Liz Cheney
isn't a hero Adam kinsinger isn't a hero
they just have principles
they're not my principles
for damn sure I mean a few of them we
maybe agree on
but they're not my [ __ ] principles
but they have them right
and there's there's Republicans in this
country that are going to go and make
sure to vote against trumpism
those those Republicans have principles
they're not mine
and that's okay we have the Liberty to
have our own principles in this country
you can have your own thought you can
have your own [ __ ] religion
you can have your own speech you're not
you're not you know
free from the consequence of any of that
but that's the Liberty that you have
that's the whole [ __ ] point
and isn't it kind of funny
that the majority of the Democrat
messaging right now is go vote go
[ __ ] vote that's like every just go
on the internet right now go to any
Democratic candidate go to any activists
go anywhere and look at their page and
see what it says
go vote go
[ __ ] vote
now go look at all the Q and honors
what's it say they're cheating we've
already lost because they're cheating
but if we win we win
if we win we win but if if they win they
cheat
Taylor's wagging the dog folks
let them wag [ __ ] them let them wag who
gives a rat's ass at this point who
cares if Elon Musk is is [ __ ]
absolutely can't help himself but to
listen to the in-cell little Bitcoin
[ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] them we can do
what we want to do put your [ __ ]
blinders on we got we got about 48 hours
and I I know I know it you're like well
the election ends before that but but
there's gonna be counting that's gonna
happen for probably the next 48 hours
they're still probably going to be
counting some of these votes Wednesday
morning and the reason why is because
there's so [ __ ] many of them I don't
know if you yeah I don't know if you've
seen the numbers but we're probably I
would imagine after today we're going to
be close to 45 or
50 million votes early voting folks
that's a shitload of [ __ ] votes
that's a huge turnout
and it's waving in democrats favor
and if that Trend continues with the
this same day voting
there is going to be races that you
didn't dream we would win that we're
going to win that democracy will come
through for us
the people who are pro-democracy who
want Liberty who want equality who want
equity
who want freedom and rights for every
single [ __ ] here in this country
that I I I'm very confident don't listen
to [ __ ] Nate silver or Elon Musk
don't listen to him
again it's the tail wagging the dog even
even [ __ ] Nate silver with his
numbers come on man dude you you're
tweeting out this morning that he's
tweeting out that oh democrats should
just uh you know rig their own polls and
throw it in the aggregate that would
make the numbers so much different and
because Democrats don't do that that
says something the [ __ ] out of here with
this nonsense
so because because liberals don't give a
[ __ ] about rather rather their [ __ ]
sheep believe something or not [ __ ] out
of here this is the problem with
narrative in this country
this is the real true problem that we
have
is that someone like Nate silver really
believes that the polls are the
narrative
he believes that this guy is supposedly
a numbers guy and a stats guy right
because they don't just do elections
they do all sorts of predictions based
on numbers
but it's just predictions the only
[ __ ] number the only count the
only tabulation the only poll that
matters
is tomorrow
that's it
that's it
that's the only one that [ __ ] matters
and all the numbers so far
do not tell the story that has been
being told in the media for the last
[ __ ] six weeks it does not tell that
story
and it's the actual poll that matters
for the numbers that we're seeing
so be confident
it's it I'm telling you
this country is sick and [ __ ] tired
of their nonsense
and by they I mean anyone anyone who
even [ __ ] has the stench of trump on
them
they're [ __ ] sick of it
sick and [ __ ] tired
someone said this morning they won a lot
of cursing in today's episode
why the [ __ ] else would you come to this
[ __ ]
why else would you come here
I'm very confident and I think you
should be too
that this is going to go very well
tomorrow it really does appear that gen
Z
has been stacked out of these polls even
even the the non-partisan actual
non-partisans they've been stacked out
of those poles
and that those numbers are showing up to
the poll that matters which is the
actual election
I want to give gen Z credit
they really did do a marvelous job in
2020 and they're doing even a better
marvelous job
here in 2022 and I hope I hope that the
fruits of their labor are seen that yes
you can
participate in policy and and politics
and elections in this country
and it makes a difference it really does
even though you may not see the bad
after the election I'll give you a
scenario let's say Democrats take the
house they take more in the Senate
they take some crucial Governor's races
and all those policies get turned around
and the fear and the the fear of these
fascists doing what they want
like demonizing lgbtq people
Banning books passing laws to take away
ranks from women
all those all the Greg Abbott down at
the border using States money as a
staged
[ __ ] thing for for fentanyl at the
border which Kevin McCarthy's talking
about this morning it's so ridiculous
we've talked about it with Texas Paul
it's all [ __ ] lies and the media just
doesn't know how to [ __ ] ask
questions
it's ridiculous but you know it is where
we're at
but gen Z is going to deliver
and again I want to give them credit
here
because the the younger vote is always
the the segment of the democratic vote
that generally is the most enthused
but doesn't actually act at the ballot
but they are
they are and if in the first time in a
long time they're very active at the
ballot
and I believe it's because they have
their whole lives in front of them and
they see what these Republicans want
they they believe they believe them okay
they [ __ ] believe them when they're
saying this [ __ ]
when they're saying stuff like well we
want to take your [ __ ] rights and
we're going to take your [ __ ] rights
away from you and and they actively are
writing bills to take people's rights
away from them especially young women
gen Z women yeah I think they I think
they're listening to them
and I think they are engaging in their
democracy
and it's important to them that they
know that these policies
are going to be in a place where they
have the same Liberty that their mothers
had
that their grandmothers had that their
aunts had
and I believe the men in the Gen Z
generation
see that as well
I I think I think
that gen Z fully understands more about
Humanity
than any other generation before them
mine mine being one that maybe
understood it a little more than the one
before me
but they understand
how the inner internet
incorporates into their daily lives
into the narrative
what's real what is not real I truly
believe that
that's why that's why these Republicans
are so terrified of gen Z they're so
terrified of pronouns they're terrified
of it
because they know that gen Z understands
the internet
they know it
and and when I say gen Z I don't mean
every single person that is born in that
generation automatically understands the
internet what I'm saying
as a as a whole
they understand the internet more than
any other generation could
you think about it I mean
they were born
not knowing anything but there's never
not been the internet
with these young adults these Young
Americans
and I believe that's why it's so
important that we put Elon Musk owning
Twitter in that context
as I know it feels like well we're
helpless now no we're not
no we're not
we are not helpless for information and
misinformation and disinformation and
lies
we're not helpless
we still have a voice
and gen Z is one of the biggest voices
that is there
and they understand exactly
what is happening before it happens they
know
it's their entire life
lives on the internet
their entire world is connected
they have discovered
how to make Humanity in this virtual
communication tool
and they do it well
and you see it in this early vote you
see it
where else where else
would these would these great young
people this great Young Generation
that's going to be our leaders here soon
where else do you think they discovered
this
other than their connections online
the decency in humanity that they and I
know I know the internet to swamp I
understand that I get it Twitter's a
swamp this is a swamp Snapchat Tick Tock
I get it I understand that
but let's not
see the force because of the trees
let's not understand that this
generation understands exactly what the
internet and the internet swamp is
and let's have some confidence in them
and let's encourage them
because I believe
I believe
they are the answer to democracy
and I'm not putting down I mean I'm a
millennial
and Millennials have taken [ __ ] forever
and everyone thinks Millennials are like
in their 20s I'm like Jesus Christ
Millennials have 401ks they got
mortgages they got [ __ ] high school
students that are their children
what are you talking about Millennials
are old some of us are getting [ __ ]
old
we're we're borderlining in that
territory where you want lower taxes so
you start voting Republican
telling you that's why elon's tweeting
when he's tweeting but you know again
you get the Millennials in their 40s and
we're coming upon that soon you get the
Millennials in their 40s and they're
going to start wanting lower taxes
they're going to start thinking about
their retirements boy they really want
to save some money
but this gen Z generation
this gen Z generation knows what's at
stake and it shows
and I'm excited about it
I'm pumped about tomorrow I am not going
I am not going to be sad tomorrow I'm
not going to say oh I'm so scared no
I am very confident about tomorrow I've
been very confident all the way up to
this point and the reason why I'm so
confident
is because I truly believe in democracy
and you the audience has proven it here
that I am correct
your engagement your frustration
you come here just to hear me [ __ ]
curse about these sons of [ __ ] yes
it's real it is strong
and we are a democracy and we are the
people
and there are more of us than there
[ __ ] are of these fascists
way more of us
there's some that that
still consider themselves Republican by
holding their nose
we can do this all you have to do is
lean in and engage in your democracy
and you can't stop after tomorrow but
right now tomorrow the election day
is the only the only subject that
matters
so like I've been saying
make sure you know
either you've already early voted or you
know where you're going to vote you've
made your plan
now I've got my plan
you make your plan and if you've already
voted and you know your vote is cast
find those three people to encourage
find them
once you find those three people to
encourage and encourage them to find
three other people go find three more
it's not going to be too late
tomorrow when you go to work when you're
on your Zoom meeting
ask
did you vote
did you vote did you vote
the turnout here is going to be the most
important thing that we have
we want to have as many balance cast and
counted as as humanly possible
I mean yes yes do high turnouts been
benefit Democrats historically sure
is that why I want the turnout somewhat
I want to send a message
just like we sent the message in 2020
because they're not getting the message
folks they're not getting it apparently
Trump is is is uh maybe going to
is maybe gonna
[ __ ] all over JD Vance's rally today I
guess I don't know I don't know if this
is real or not some people are tweeting
that some people are saying that he's
going to announce today it was supposed
to be the 14th now he's going to
announce today
he's getting indicted that's that's why
he's going to announce to run there
would be no other reason what the [ __ ]
the reason to announce today at JD
Vance's rally then he's then he's fear
he fears indictment
which good [ __ ] him let him run I think
it's a beautiful idea oh hell's to the
yeah
let them let them have to [ __ ] be
coupled to that [ __ ]
for the entirety of every single [ __ ]
court case that is going to be dropped
on this [ __ ] yeah sure let's do
that let's make that part of the
Republican primary yeah and watch them
all step aside for his criminal ass
or will they or will they fight against
him will they turn on him hmm I'm all
for that fight [ __ ] them let them do it
let them fight it out he's not running
for president now for the general
election he's got to run a primary folks
[ __ ] him let him run
let him I I wish he would announce two
months ago
a [ __ ] [ __ ] box do it you [ __ ] do it
stop [ __ ] toying around with it do it
you goddamn little [ __ ]
because nothing would be better nothing
would be better in this country and I
know people like oh my God he'll run the
country if he runs he's got to run
against Republicans folks
he's got to run against Republicans
first he doesn't just get handed the
nomination tomorrow
if he's the nominee
and Ron DeSantis has a clear path so
yeah let's do that
and I hope I hope that he affects the
2022 midterm by announcing today
if he announces today that affects the
election tomorrow I do not want him to
wait
everything right now in this moment is
about tomorrow every [ __ ] thing
even Kathy Griffin having her account
suspended is about tomorrow
all of it
make it about tomorrow that's your
narrative you control what you say you
control what you do
you control how you react you control
how you engage
that's the most beautiful part about the
politics
of our government
because there's two things
there's policy which is the governing
right you know where they're passing
bills and and writing bills and getting
line items that everyone wants
that's the policy part and then there's
the election the politics
the narrative
how we drive elections how we win to set
policy because you do not get to set
policy if you do not win
you just wait and see
if gray Abbott wins he'll set policy if
Ron DeSantis wins he'll set policy
if Kemp wins he'll set policy if Kerry
Lake wins which is the race they want
the most that's the race they want the
most folks is Carrie Lake if Carrie Lake
wins she'll set policy
you don't get to have a [ __ ] saying
policy
so play the politics play The Narrative
it's yours to play You're the voter
you're the narrative
you're the one with the voice so go play
politics [ __ ] em
and make everything about tomorrow every
single thing about tomorrow because it
is the most important election of our
democracy's lifetime
right now in this moment we're right
here
the ball is on the tee folks all we have
to do is knock that [ __ ] out of
the park
it's right there just aim swing and hit
it hard
and swing all the way through that son
of a [ __ ]
all the way through it so get your plan
go vote encourage three people to vote
get those three people to encourage
three more once you find your three to
encourage
find three more
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
and the [ __ ] lives around up here really
[Music]
I really want him to announce at the JD
van
I really do and more than anything when
he announces that he's running for
president I want him to get JD Vamps his
name wrong again
JD Mandel or JP is it JD well who is it
who I don't know who that is
I I don't I don't know if he's gonna
announce I don't know I have no idea
it would be great if he did today though
wouldn't it this would be fantastic
if he shits all over Republicans chances
in 2022 because he announces right
before this
what's what's funny
what's funny
is that people are going to think that
somehow that would put them over the top
listen listen there were almost eight
million more votes for Biden
and that was before January 6th okay
folks he lost the popular vote in 2016.
this [ __ ] is not popular at all
81 million people told him to take a
[ __ ] hike in 2020 and again that was
before he tried to remain his dictator
and and sicked his shark army on our
[ __ ] Institution
the government and tried to steal our
vote and they continue to try to steal
our vote
they they are not the majority at all
not even close and not only that the
majority is sick of their [ __ ] [ __ ]
so him him announcing today at JD
Vance's rally oh my God yes do that
please
get out on the [ __ ] stage now
in front of the microphone and announce
now right [ __ ] now
stop being such a goddamn little [ __ ]
and announce
quit being a [ __ ]
he won't though
he won't
but folks who gives a [ __ ] act like he's
going to I'm telling you I'm telling you
when you go talk to someone who's really
unsure about voting at this point
tell them Donald Trump's gonna announce
he's gonna run for president so now so
now the Republicans when they take over
they're gonna they're gonna do anything
he wants
who gives a [ __ ] you don't think people
are gonna well [ __ ] I'm gonna go vote
tomorrow I wasn't thinking about voting
you God damn right I'm gonna go vote now
look this country is not Trump country
okay there are parts of it that are
totally [ __ ] deluded that are totally
out of their goddamn Minds
but it's a small percentage of of folks
it's a large number right like when you
start stacking up how many [ __ ]
people believe this garbage it's a large
number but it's a small percentage
it's a small percentage
and I am I am 100 okay with their entire
party playing and placating
to the small percentage
and let the Tail Wag the Dog who gives a
[ __ ]
better for us
for the people who know the [ __ ]
truth because folks that's the craziest
part about this whole goddamn timeline
that we're in
it's the it's the craziest part about it
all
thank you
is that literally everyone says the
truth is dead
it is not dead it is [ __ ] alive folks
it's more alive now than it's ever been
people now realize what the truth is
they know what truth is
you know what they have to do they just
have to listen to someone like Elon Musk
or Trump or their incels or their shart
Army and go well that's a [ __ ] lie
during his entire presidency and really
his his campaign and ever since he got
kicked out of the [ __ ] white house
because Joe Biden dunked on his ass in
this last election in 2020 absolutely
smoked him
from the basement sleepy Joe smoked him
rolled him up and [ __ ] smoked him
I always
whenever he would say something whenever
he would tweet something whenever he'd
put out a statement
whatever he was saying I automatically
believed 100 was not true that's where I
started
that's where I started why do you think
so many [ __ ] people are early voting
is it because they believe this nonsense
that early voting is is somehow fraud
no it's because they're saying it and
they're like well that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] because they're saying it
come on that's why everyone's going in
early voting that's why there's so many
people there are more people in the 2022
midterm early voting
then there were in 2020 when we had a
[ __ ] pandemic
think about it think about it
think about it
people are not believing their [ __ ]
yes I get it there's a lot of delusional
people out there they're always happen
in this country
there always have been but we as a
narrative give them way too much [ __ ]
credit
that's why I [ __ ] that's why I
[ __ ] mock them all the time
so I continue to do it
because it's all fraud I don't know if
you've watched any tape from this rally
that he had
um I I think it was was in Iowa where
the [ __ ] was this one I don't know
I'm going to show you a video of someone
standing on the on the media platform
where they do like a 360 on the media
platform
right
it's all a bunch of [ __ ] and eighty
percent of the [ __ ] it's their
50th rally and [ __ ]
these are concerts these aren't
political rallies it's a [ __ ] setup
it's a fraud it's a phony
it's not real it's all to convince you
that their lies are working and they're
not
they're not working folks the [ __ ]
early vote numbers prove it
believe your [ __ ] eyes
believe the truth not the [ __ ] that
they spent on Facebook and nothing
against family if you're watching here
on Facebook Hey great
but your Uncle Earl the [ __ ] he's
posting about a red wave and how it's
the media is even saying CNN there's
even saying Bubba get the [ __ ] out of
here with that nonsense
don't believe that garbage it's just
garbage anyways
it's a garbage narrative it's a bunch of
[ __ ] lies and not not not the
majority of people in this country are
believing that garbage that [ __ ]
that vile nasty [ __ ] they just aren't
believing it
that the number one problem in the
country is that children are getting
their wieners chopped off now No One
Believes that garbage Matt Walsh No One
Believes that [ __ ] Marjorie Taylor
green
they do not believe that [ __ ]
they don't believe that early voting is
bad that it's fraudulent they do not
believe that we have to [ __ ] let
Republicans in because that's what
happens in our country during midterms
is that the opposite party takes power
in the Congress after a president wins
they're not believing that garbage
they're just not so don't believe the
[ __ ]
engage
lean into democracy
like I always say here Gabe Sanchez is
going to be joining us here in just a
few minutes we're going to go through
the shitless Roundup I want to show you
that video I got plenty of videos to
show you but I want to show you that
video to prove to you
that all these Trump rallies they're
frauds it's uh fraud it's all [ __ ]
I'll show it to you
and the [ __ ] list Roundup I have a few
other videos I want to show you Kevin
McCarthy was apparently on this morning
these journalists just don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing how to ask
questions of these morons talking about
fentanyl lying about fentanyl more and
more and more lies about fentanyl
remember remember it was the Halloween
candy was going to kill hundreds of
millions of children because oh man all
these people are coming across the
border fitting on buying houses and
they're going to set up shop and pass
out Halloween Skittles that have
Fentanyl and it's going to kill your
children not a thing not a [ __ ] thing
oh I'm sure I'm sure everyone believed
that nope didn't
even though the mini was pushing the
[ __ ]
Now Kevin McCarthy probably probably
doesn't even know what Halloween is a
Halloween what's Halloween I have no
idea I have no idea so he's spreading
more lines about fentanyl now the
Halloween's past he can't talk about how
they're going to put it in
in your in your [ __ ] Eminem bags for
Halloween now you gotta lie about
something else they're gonna watch that
we have a few more videos I have a I
have some videos I want to show you it's
called Roe versus bro oh my God these
videos are so [ __ ] good I don't know
if you've seen them
it's it's fantastic
it's fantastic to watch men because men
do not know anything about women they
really don't
even the best of us have no [ __ ] clue
we just don't know
and that's okay it's okay that men don't
know how
tampons work that's what I call them
tampons
it's okay dudes it's all right that you
don't know how tampons work I don't know
never used one
but here's the thing dude
you shouldn't be telling someone what to
do when you don't even know how that
[ __ ] works
you're not you shouldn't be telling them
what to do and this video makes it
very clear very clear
about how men don't even know how
tampons work so
they shouldn't be telling women what to
do with their [ __ ] bodies they're
great videos they're great videos have
you seen these videos these uh bro
versus bro Gabe Sanchez have you seen
these these new videos uh yeah I have
and they're pretty they're yeah oh
there's [ __ ] hand well they're great
because I think you know obviously
majority of men the point being right
men don't know about women so if you
can't answer basic questions then why
are you in charge of making the
decisions for those women about their
bodies right everyone's talking in the
um in the chat here they apparently they
don't know like how I say tampon it's a
tampon
whoever calls it tampon it's a tampon
it's tampon what see this shows how much
I know this shows how much I should be
regulating women's bodies anyone who
looks like me or talks calls it a tampon
should not be regulating women's bodies
let them do the work it's it's
ridiculous but they're they're talking
about how I say yeah you got it I have
never I've never in my life heard the
word tampon I have not had to ask for
I've heard people say I'm going camping
right but I've never going camping and
mate you might want to you know take a
tampon look just in case look here's the
thing this is the same thing with the
salsa right same thing same [ __ ] same
[ __ ] it's just how I say words and
that's just how it's gonna [ __ ] be
that's just same [ __ ] different day so
let's let's go to the shitless Roundup
let's watch some videos about tampons
start the countdown
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome welcome back to the show I guess
we're going to talk about a lot of
tampons everyone's got the tampon talk
going in the chat but first thing I want
to do Gabe is show you this video this
is from Trump's rally and I don't know
where the hell did you see it is this
the reigning one
I don't I don't know because he got
rained in on in one right yeah yeah the
one last night I think it was just like
imagine what the makeup looked like
after he got on the plane oh it was uh
he had a hat on though didn't he yeah he
had a hat on but I mean like you know
you've got to imagine that there's
makeup that's just like bleeding down
have you ever seen one of those art
pieces where people take a bunch of uh
crayons and they glue them to the top of
a cake melts yeah and they heat it and
they melt it I would imagine it's kind
of like that except all down his jacket
right and his red tie and yeah yeah I
would love to see a picture of that but
the video that I got here is is a video
of the crowd so this person is standing
on the media platform right okay we we
all know the shtick of trump where he's
like oh and the media won't turn their
cameras around or they turn their
cameras off or whatever and he's talking
about left wing media which there's no
left-wing media standing on the on the
stage right he's like these people won't
cover and it's like these are the only
people that are like these people won't
cover the Russia Russia Russia hoax or
this or that or whatever it's like no
these are those people but they're
[ __ ] getting sued for billions of
dollars for defamation for the election
so all the trader TV news networks are
the only ones having cameras on the
[ __ ] platform because the news is
like well if they're gonna record it
we'll just play it as a clip from their
Network so it doesn't appear that we're
[ __ ] covering this garbage but here's
here's the image here you can see
um they're pointed towards the the stage
in the plane here where he's talking now
apparently he
he he did like a Mussolini thing where
he got off the the plane and he walked
down the steps of the plane and he kind
of walks across the platform he does his
stupid giraffe jerk off dance yeah right
right you know we were talking about
that the other day where he looks like
he's jerking off giraffes and then he
it's it's a great day it never really is
it's like you know it's either you're
doing a very big
like uh like flossing between the ears
right kind of thing or
yeah you're just jerking off your F's
right I think it's definitely jerking
off yeah so I mean you know you can say
you're flossing between his ears but I
don't know that there's anything in
floss but you see in the in the in the
uh you see uh Trump's very tiny hands I
mean a very he's kind of tiny there on
the screen there at the podium right on
this on this little stage now
normally they would have the bleachers
behind him right right because they want
the imagery of this big crowd behind him
but they've changed it they've changed
it to have uh Trump farce one behind him
so that way his name appears on all the
broadcast with his plane which is you
know
we all we all know that's that's why
it's that way now the craziest part here
is that a lot of people even people who
maybe listen to this show think that
this guy has a lot of people showing up
to his rallies now the other thing that
they've been doing on the trader News
network is they've been bringing these
people up on stage and they interview
him like how many rallies have you been
to they're like this is my 556 rally
like it's a [ __ ] concert or some [ __ ]
you know these are like and I don't want
to insult deadheads right yeah but these
are these are [ __ ] groupies they're
not they're not this is not a political
rally this is like a concert thing that
they're going to in costume it's an
event it's a concert it's it's not it's
not politics these people are are a cult
it's a [ __ ] cult oh yeah yeah okay so
we see this image but this person I'm
gonna mute it because you know I don't
need to hear what the [ __ ] they're
saying but
um watch as zoom in and look at that
Zooms in on the on the old trumpy bear
there and then watch as they spin
look how many people aren't there Gabe
like what are these are these media
tables okay so these are immediate so
this is the media pen here right yeah
yes the quote-unquote right the press
the Press pin right yeah because
generally generally speaking there's you
know at these political events you want
to have it covered very well so you want
to press all around the world not a lot
of press though you can see how much
press they're getting
or not yeah um but then they zoom in
here's the background it looks like
there there might be a
um I don't know if Lauren bobert has
like a mobile
um [ __ ] Burger mobile or something you
know she's got those loose diarrhea
sandwiches I think that's what's going
on she's big into slider so she's like
slide him in slide them out you know
I probably slide out yeah oh my God so
there's a there's a food truck back
there apparently that is the the extent
of the concessions is the one food truck
and they're not having any trouble
serving this crowd at all
um because it's just not very big
um and they're just they don't even seem
enthused right no here's the thing not a
lot of activity I mean these people are
just like all the way in the back right
just waiting you know like I'm sure they
wouldn't have any issue of getting up
closer I guess but also I mean there's
plenty of seats here
there's plenty of room for them to kind
of go but but maybe maybe it's just that
you know
he sells certain tickets where you can
go certain places or something I have
nobody I always I always love how these
rallies that he puts on have if you go
over there's he's got Cherry Pickers
that are always set up
uh so there's one right there with the
flag but then if you go to the right
when they when they initially pan
boom right there okay so you got a fork
like sorry not a forklift you got a
cherry picker up there and they've got a
flag or speakers or whatever it's I
don't know what this this whole rally
every time he puts one on they're so
like Jerry rigged where he's got these
Cherry Pickers that are hoisting up
flags that just like wave in them into
the wind you know and then he's got like
uh he's got a huge monitor or screen
that's displaying himself for the people
in the back who can't see and he's got
hard to see him like right he's got 80
feet away yeah he's got others he's huge
he's [ __ ] huge like how can't you
spot unless and just for the audience uh
if anybody didn't know this so This
Trump farts one plane that he's got
right now uh his his plane had engine
trouble back in March of 2021.
and I covered this on on uh not the last
what was that idea but the one previous
to that
basically
in March of 2021 he was like oh no my
engines got trouble guess what and what
does he do
he sends out an email
not too long after that says like all
right my supporters uh I'm gonna milk
you guys dry to help fund my brand new
Trump plane that I haven't announced yet
but I'm announcing right now but don't
tell anybody
and then of course everyone's like oh my
God I gotta donate I gotta get him his
plane well here's the thing he never
built the plane he never bought a plane
whoa wait he never fell on me he snaked
money away from his supporters come on
just saying just saying but so anyway he
he milked a bunch of money grifted a
bunch of money from people under the
promise that a new plane would be built
never did it then this plane which had
just been hanging out in a hangar for a
time he's just paying a rent on this
plane that needed uh repairs used that
money
you know again going to the Super PAC
the save America Super PAC or the save
America pack uh funds the repairs for
this plane doesn't get a new plane and
then debuts this plane I think maybe two
rallies ago or three rallies ago where
he made his Grand entry oh it was two
rallies ago it was one it was in Texas
in Robstown in Robstown Texas because he
and Alina Haba flew on the plane
together right because everyone's like
whoa is he gonna fly to Texas are you
going to fly to Russia they weren't
really exactly yeah I mean he could that
trip is a smaller plane but it does
allow
to you know it can make it across the
Atlantic if it needs to
um but yeah it's it is something else to
I wanna I wanna play this while we're
talking here because this is a rally
somewhere
um that happened and you know you you I
don't know you you decide
um which one is bigger and more
enthusiastic here even without the sound
right you can tell
um now I don't know if you know where
this was at but this was uh over the
weekend in Philadelphia
and this was not a republican rally this
is a
Democratic party rally a lot more people
a lot more enthusiasm right really
honestly just a lot more well done it
just looks better it also like it's not
out in the hay field or on a Tarmac well
here's they can actually rent a venue I
don't know right they can actually rent
a venue and then they can actually pay
for the vendors and the services and the
staff and the help and get the venue
packed right well and these are all
things that we know that Trump has a
just
horrible a reputation of not being able
to pay people back so if you're gonna if
you're gonna defend Trump and say he's a
great job Builder a job Creator he does
this and does that [ __ ] because
there are literally cities where he owes
two million plus dollars in actual
services for security transportation and
also a a late fee percentage that's on
there so I see I see fake Gabe and some
other people saying is this the extent
of Democratic or democrat talking points
not the economy not war not fuel prices
it's Trump playing the reason I bring up
Trump's plane is to show everyone the
person that is the head of the party
right now the person that all of the
trumpers and including yourself vote to
support and want to run in 2024 is the
guy that's grifting you from all your
money is the guy that doesn't create
jobs is the guy that steals money
Griff's money will lie cheap
kills whatever to make sure that he
is secure he doesn't care about anyone
else the Republican party has also
proved that to be true time and time
again and the reason I bring that up and
what Tony's bringing up right now is to
show a contrast here to show you exactly
who is fighting for rights women's
rights your rights people of color
voting rights these are things that are
actually being fought for
by the the Democratic party not by
Republicans if you ain't got the right
to exist who gives a [ __ ] about gas
prices I mean here's here's if you look
at this rally and just the messaging
here right
um
you're going to see vote vote vote right
all around it doesn't say Joe Biden yeah
it doesn't say Barack Obama doesn't say
fetterman it says vote yeah like they're
literally the Democrats message is hey
use your voice and the Republicans are
like Trump Trump trump and trumpity
Trump trump and Trump trump and Trump
trump and more Trump by the way and if
you ain't got enough Trump here we'll
stick some more Trump in your face
because that's what that's what those
rallies are right here and he he
endorses election deniers right this
election denialism which sprouted pretty
much out of trump in the subverting the
2020 election but this is something that
the Republican Party does again and
again you've got Trump holding these
rallies trying to show that this
candidate or he's valid or whatever it
is but again it's always Trump is being
like wow dad and he's always projecting
and complaining about his own problems
using right using the rally as a way to
say beautiful home Mom like I mean the
problem is the problem is because
they're so hell-bent and focused in on
Trump is they can't put a policy
together to save their [ __ ] lives I
mean we're still waiting on that
two-week health care plan right so well
and we're still waiting on a
Republican's policy on how they're going
to fix inflation
and how they're gonna how they're going
to lower gas prices as gas prices are
lowering right now as we speak it really
is [ __ ] bone-headed stuff and here's
more bone-headed [ __ ] from the Speaker
of the House
are who they want to be the speaker of
this if they win Now Kevin McCarthy here
says [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] about fentanyl now
this reporter you know God bless her
heart but why isn't she asking about all
the Halloween candy when he talks about
fentanyl why but let's let's listen to
this just listen on the border um if
you're a speaker what will you
specifically do to secure the Border
well there's a number of things I think
stay in Mexico you have to right off the
bat
um you've got to stop the cartel's
control of the Border you've got to stop
fentanyl from coming across
okay we've already established this
several times on the show with Texas
Paul several times it is not again it is
not
people of color bringing fentanyl across
the border it is white people from this
country going to Mexico and getting
fentanyl but the majority of the
fentanyl is not coming across the border
it's not and they're catching a shitload
of it Republicans even admit that
they're seizing a lot of it at the
border because it comes through the
gates in vehicles not across the [ __ ]
wall when people are trying to get to
this country to seek Refuge right now
it's also a terrible business plan like
why would you give this [ __ ] away from
why would you travel
hundreds or thousands of miles wherever
you're coming from to bring it across
the country into the U.S to only give it
away for free on Halloween right to kill
like that doesn't but here's the
craziest part he doesn't he's dropped
the whole Halloween thing the whole
Halloween narrative is gone and the
reason why is because it was all [ __ ]
lie there's a [ __ ] lie it was a lie
to get fake Gabe to say it on chat rooms
like this you see how that works fake
they they convinced you that fentanyl
was going to be placed in Halloween
candy Skittle bags to get you to go into
chat rooms and say that [ __ ] that's what
they were doing so they've dropped that
narrative because none of it was true
it's it's now [ __ ] we all know that
because Halloween's already happened but
here is Kevin McCarthy spreading more
[ __ ] lies about fentanyl listen
fentanyl when you think about it is a
chemical of mass destruction
it is killing our next Generation it's
the number one killer of Americans
between the ages of 18 and 45. okay
fentanyl is an opioid fentanyl is a
[ __ ] opioid opioid and Fentanyl are
[ __ ] legal here in the United States
to use for doctors to prescribe for pain
and the reason why so many people are
[ __ ] dying is because Republicans are
taking big money from Big Pharma for
opioids
why the [ __ ] do you think Republicans
are against against anything that has to
do with THC right well number one
Democrats are for the decriminalization
of marijuana and that's the number one
reason why they're against it but the
the other reason why is because big
Pharma with fentanyl with opioids more
than anything else are in the pockets of
[ __ ] Republicans yes they have
Democrats too but just go look at how
much [ __ ] money Marcia Blackburn's
taken from [ __ ] opioid pushers the
big Pharma and then go look at how her
state is ravaged with opioid over to his
desk this has nothing to do with
fentanyl you dumb [ __ ] fentanyl
is just the next one it's the next one
it's the next one this is an opioid
problem this is a health care problem in
this country that's what this is this is
a health care crisis and Kevin McCarthy
doesn't want to talk about that and the
reason none of them do well yeah right
because they would have to come up with
a [ __ ] solution right other than
other than shooting people who come
across the border that's their solution
for the fentanyl problem well the other
the other thing too is they would have
to admit like they would have to
actually identify what the problem is
right not just all the fentanyl the
fentanyls are probably it's like okay
cool all right but
how how did we get here right right how
was the fentanyl accessible to these
people is it because we over prescribe
these drugs is it because we have
legislators that run policies that are
uh Pro Pharma because they've been
lobbied to do so right like you know if
no one's seen the Hulu uh miniseries
um dope sick you should you definitely
should it's with Michael Keaton it it
talks about that in the Appalachia
region and how opioids have affected so
many of these Blue Collar areas uh into
a point of
um you know addiction and breaking down
homes that the American values are at
risk because
these people don't have the livelihood
to support their family to support you
know food on the table they become
houseless all these things you would
think that Republicans would care about
those things right
to make sure that hard-working coal
mining uh you know blue-collar jobs
would would be cared for but they don't
care if they go oh well the real problem
is these drugs coming across the border
no it's just like it's just like anyone
that you want to blame on illegal aliens
they came in Legally overstayed their
visa and never left that's not the
people there's not a caravan of people
that's coming across the border and also
when Republicans want to say oh we
apprehended these people who try to come
across the border or we seize these
drugs that came across the border you
really are showing yourself to be a fool
because what it's proving is that there
actually is border security that there
actually are policies under the
Democrats that prove that what is work
what they're using or what they're doing
is working as opposed to we let these
many million of pounds come into the
countries like no they were seized open
a [ __ ] Dictionary look up what these
terms mean and understand that when when
they are seized or when they're
apprehended or when they're arrested or
they're taken or they're returned or
whatever it is
that it proves that there is a a a
barrier of Entry it proves that there is
something working because we literally
haven't we we got it we obtained it we
didn't allow it to get across the border
but Republicans of course don't want to
acknowledge those things they don't
understand basic terminology yeah but
the thing but the thing is they also
don't want to acknowledge The Human
Condition is that exactly human humans
are going to do drugs that you are not
going to stop human beings from getting
high you're not going to do it we tried
this [ __ ] in our country over a hundred
years ago with prohibition we tried that
[ __ ] and and it failed miserably it
actually backfired and had the opposite
effect of what they were looking for
right the actual opposite effect
so prohibition is not the answer it we
do not have a drug problem in this
country it never has been a drug problem
The Human Condition is to do drugs and
to seek drones whether it's to get high
recreationally whether it's just to
solve a pain problem rather it's a
self-medicated a mental problem that you
have humans seek drugs it is a thing
that they are going to do right what we
have in this country is a health care
problem we have a health care problem
the human problem is always going to
exist we are always going to have people
who seek out drugs that we are not going
to change that that is something we
cannot change yes will our can our
society move forward and there be less
less addiction than more sure absolutely
but there's always going to be that and
it doesn't have to be just just actual
drugs like opioids or alcohol it can be
a multi attitude of drugs
it can be any kind of thing that that
causes your brain to have a heightened
of endorphins now right because we know
that human condition that is why they
avoid it it's because when you have when
you have a problem like health care when
you have that problem what they do is
they solve it by causing more of a
problem because it's more profitable
that way that's why the pharmaceutical
companies love Republicans they love
Republicans because Republicans are with
are more than willing to to absolutely
blame drugs and then at the same time
pile tons of drugs because they're legal
they're prescription they're not it's
not illicit right it's not illicit and
that is what's happening in these
communities that is what happened is
happening all around the country
is that people they are not
distinguishing the difference people are
gonna do drugs and you can't prevent
them from doing it you can't you won't
it won't happen I mean the only you know
it's it's very much like uh you know
obviously there's different parenting
methods right and you you can totally uh
lock down your child and say you can't
do this and you can't do that which
obviously we've heard stories of
someone's like once they get out of the
house they go [ __ ] wild because
they've never experienced certain things
and there's something to be said if it's
like oh you look at other countries as
well you look at how they've regulated
uh uh you know recreational drugs right
it turns out that if you were to
actually put it's [ __ ] idiot more
racist [ __ ] Jesus uh you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] who cares if George Floyd had a
prescription or not it doesn't matter
fentanyl by the way is a prescription
opioid dummy it is a prescription opioid
so regardless if he had it or not it's a
legal [ __ ] drug that's what that's
what Republicans don't want to tell you
that get fake Gabe that's why you're the
Trump copy machine is because you don't
know [ __ ] [ __ ] you don't know [ __ ]
fentanyl is a legal [ __ ] [ __ ] drug
that's why the and Texas paulus told you
this fake Gabe I don't know if you you
seem to be here when he's here the
majority of fentanyl comes in a small
little package from China through the
United States mail or UPS
or or at FedEx it's all coming in little
bitty doses dummy and and it's and and
what they do is they cut it up and then
distribute it and it's not it's not
people of color it's Chad it's the white
dude Chad down the street you know the
guy that's got the shed out back that's
that's who it is that's who it is fake
Gabe that's who's given illegal it's
also incredibly easy to get in terms of
uh just a prescription I mean I remember
when I got my wisdom teeth taken out I
was given Vicodin yep Vicodin I don't
respond to Vicodin it literally does
nothing they're like okay we'll give you
oxy like he's like he was like oh that
doesn't work yeah sure okay we'll just
prescribe you out and it was like okay
do you want some brown horse heroin too
you wanna I mean you want a heroin
cocktail to go with that I mean it'll
help it's crazy how easy that somebody
could like oh yeah whatever okay it's no
problem right I mean if that's you know
they're like oh you're not going to
abuse it and that's the where that's
where it starts right like you've got
these receptors and they attach on they
say oh I love that high how do I get
that high again right some people
obviously have more addictive qualities
to their to themselves and other people
don't but it when you have a very
addictive uh drug that makes you feel
good your body no pain no aches nothing
like that then your body's gonna you
know it's gonna seek that out more
naturally as a human
you're going to seek out the things that
make you feel good right whether it's a
drug to kind of subdue the feelings or
kind of heighten those feelings whatever
it might be your body is going to
naturally do that so again like Tony
said as humans we naturally are going to
go and you think we drink we smoke we do
whatever
and that is how we are we're also
naturally curious humans I've even said
that I've even said that and I've said
that on the show that's the reason why I
don't think I could smoke marijuana is
because I'm a former cigarette smoker
and I think that causing me just to
smoke I I don't think I think it would
have a natural effect on me that I would
want the drug of smoking because it's
not just about the nicotine sometimes
it's about the Habit speaking of really
bad [ __ ] habits and people who want
to take away your [ __ ] health care
because they have no solution uh at all
um Rick's got here he come up with the
great Republican plan to strip away your
Medicare and your Social Security so go
vote for Republicans if you don't want
to have social security or Medicare but
here listen to this little Gaff here he
he has uh Gabe listen to this we're
gonna have a big win on Tuesday we're
gonna get rid of doll we're gonna get
rid of Joe Biden what what was that what
was that oh wait watch again I know I
don't mean to take away your thunder on
you no no listen listen we're gonna have
a big win on Tuesday yeah we're gonna
get rid of doll we're gonna get rid of
Joe Biden I think he right yeah sort of
like it sounded like uh Skeletor himself
right was about to say get rid of Donald
Trump right
uh he wants he wants to get rid of
Donald sleepy Joe so he wants to get rid
of this guy watch this watch this clip
this shows how inept and really how uh
dementia ridden Joe Biden truly is watch
this clip King a quick reminder
vote go to iwillvote.com to find out
where and how
again I don't know how else to explain
this that the Democrats messaging
literally is go vote go [ __ ] they're not
like go vote for Democrats they're like
just go just go vote because I I have to
tell you that I think most pro-democracy
people in this country who are excited
about voting who are excited about their
democracy who are willing to crawl over
broken glass and hot coals to go vote
believe that the majority of people are
also willing to do that and they're very
confident if the turnout is high then we
will have a huge turnout and and women
are going to be a crucial part of that
so I want to go to the tampon the tampon
videos
um this is what
yeah it's something like uh you know
that you take out the Trish yeah you you
get rid of the garbage yeah nope that's
uh never never would say it like that no
you know what to each their own right
right right well that's true but let's
watch how these gentlemen in this video
know exactly know exactly how tampons
work and more importantly how a woman's
body at they have no [ __ ] clue let's
watch can you pee with a tampon I don't
think it's recommended welcome to
another episode of Roe v Bros the game
show where we find out how much men know
about women's bodies can you pee with a
tampon in
I think you got to take it out I've seen
the little tampon trash cans in the uh
bathrooms so probably why why are there
different types of tampons
[Music]
different sizes of vaginal cavities
[Music]
how many tampons what
floor period on average
[Music]
oh two
one to be honest one and they put them
aside
[Music]
what is a period what is a period it's
uh the time of the month where the woman
is ovulating can you pee with a tampon
in are you registered to vote yes are
you registered to vote Yes yes are you
registered to vote Yes yes don't let man
brains outvote women in the upcoming
election vote November 8th
fantastic videos fantastic here's what
here's what I want to say though yeah
the reason why men do not believe that
you can pee with the tampon in is
because a dude could not pee if he put a
tampon in like if he yeah right because
well I mean they're also I I think a lot
of guys don't understand there's two
right that's what I'm saying so I'm
saying yeah that right we have
one they got two two I I will say they
don't get it they don't get it
I'm sorry the one guy the only one where
I'm like yeah okay maybe okay whatever
you know excuse that you weren't
educated or or you know really wasn't
taught in school or you didn't listen to
it in health class or whatever it was
but the one where I'm like holy [ __ ] the
guy was like oh yeah one tampon I'm like
all right do we like does anybody know
about toxic shock syndrome like that is
something where you would be like listen
I'm [ __ ] gross I'm telling you you
know I'm dangerous right but here's the
thing though is that really honestly
just like men should not have to be
required to know every single in and out
of a tampon how to put it in how many
you got to use whether you pee within it
or not is the same reason why men should
not be telling women what to do with
their health care right like it's the
same [ __ ] it's the same like we
shouldn't be expected to know these
things I don't know just like reading
about women and I don't claim to and
right and it's look not my area of
expertise in terms of like the female
you know everything that happens not my
body I would much rather uh the woman in
that scenario
they know best right uh they should be
able to decide those things and
obviously the medical expert their
doctor their OB GYN
they should be the ones making decision
not your local politician by the way not
some guy who decides oh yeah that's how
this works or it doesn't understand like
there was that one uh there was that one
video of the guy who thought that you
could ingest the camera pill yeah and it
would and it would come end up in their
vagina end up in their vagina so keep in
mind you swallow it goes down and you're
stomach he literally doesn't even know
how he shits like he has no clue how he
shits and they're like it ends up in
your vagina and you're like what
women don't [ __ ] after anyways Benny
logo says she knows how dicks work I
mean it's it's obvious out dick it's
pretty okay Dick's very easy they're
very straightforward why why look if
there is a God because I don't actually
believe that but if there is one why
wouldn't he give the man the easy tool
the one that was easy to understand
that's the whole point is there's
probably I I forget who says it I think
it's um I think it was uh Robin Williams
said there's only enough blood to run
one head at a time yeah right and I
think that was Robin Williams joke and
you can't you do not have a man does not
have enough blood in his body right to
run his brain and his penis so obviously
that's why that would happen that way
through Evolution or if you believe in
spirituality and you have faith and you
believe in God fine maybe God did that
it we did definitely gave women the more
complicated thing to understand because
they're smarter than men here's another
video to prove it here's another one of
these Ro versus bro let's watch can you
show us with your hands on how to insert
a tampon
okay that makes sense and then welcome
to another episode of Roe v Bros the
game show where we find out how much men
know about women's bodies all right so
we're gonna let you choose on the board
uh our first question
let's let's go with sex how long do you
have to wait after birth until you can
have sex
uh maybe leaving the hospital
so immediately pretty much
[Music]
great how much blood is there um for the
average period
oh gee I'm not really good with
measurements um
[Music]
Port is smaller than a pie
yes I would imagine a new tampon every
day
so each day of the period okay why are
there different sizes of tampons
uh because there are different sizes of
vaginas I imagine are you registered to
vote yeah
yeah are you registered to vote I'm
registered to vote are you registered to
vote
let man brains outvote women in the
upcoming election vote November 8th
oh my God
okay I'm just like man come on guys it's
you did you say tampon it's tampon okay
just like those dudes they probably say
tamping too right exactly if any wine
this is why I don't advocate for me as a
dude to tell women what the [ __ ] they
can and can't do inside their doctor's
office because I have no I don't even
know the name of them I don't even say
it correctly right I wouldn't even know
honestly I like these guys because the
one where he says like put it in and
he's like use your hands and he's you
know like I wouldn't even know when I go
in the store what I'm looking for to buy
like like I've been down the tampon Isle
I've walked through the aisle I'd be
like how the [ __ ] do they know and the
reason the other reason why guys are
like oh there's different size tampons
because different size vaginas is
because that's how it works for a wiener
with condoms yeah like there's different
size condoms for a different size again
they got man brains which is barely any
brains at all and that is the reason why
we should not let men control Women's
Health Care control decisions about
women's bodies and we definitely
definitely should not leave it to a
[ __ ] local politician this is really
stupid stuff and I believe
I believe that gen Z
in particular the women and and even the
the men in gen Z are like this is
ridiculous like Min and gen Z are like I
don't know how a tampon works I should
definitely not be telling a woman what
to do with her body or what her and her
doctor can I mean there are there are
definitely a few lessons to be learned
from these videos but just overall the
way in which Republicans have talked
about women's rights and making the
decision between their medical you know
you got Dr Oz a a doctor I mean he's a
bit of a quack doctor but a doctor that
knows the the human anatomy the female
anatomy and how you're supposed to it he
went to school studied it did this and
and was a a talking head on a on a talk
show to help different people I mean
yeah he obviously tried to push uh fake
kind of pharmaceutical or like fake kind
of like supplements and whatnot but you
would think that Dr Oz a board-certified
doctor would know what to say and
especially would know that the decisions
that are made are only between the woman
and the doctor and possibly you know her
partner in that case but those are
things between your own body and your
own uh medical uh physician right the
person that knows exactly how your body
works and knows how to answer questions
and give you help so if there's any
lesson you learned from these videos I
think there are two one uh always just
always give women the the the right and
power to choose how they want to use
their own body two
we need to
definitely fund public education and sex
education within public education might
be a good idea Margie points out a good
point today on fun with phonics because
I mean obviously I didn't even grow up
knowing
um what what a tampon is I don't even
know how to say it apparently uh more
more man brains here on Tony Michael's
podcast here's some more man brains uh
Ron DeSantis did you see the picture of
him when he was a teacher he was hanging
out with high schoolers drinking beer
with him this is kind of funny I have I
have not seen this picture much it
doesn't be circulating too much around
it's almost like you know he doesn't
practice what he preaches
um here he is though saying some really
stupid [ __ ]
um not about tampons but about our
constitution it's almost as dumb as some
of these gentlemen you just saw thought
that you can't pee with a tampon and
listen we need to teach them then in the
American system our rights come from God
not not from the government
you know it's really funny how these
[ __ ] have been running around for the
last 40 years with their pocket
constitutions and [ __ ] yeah and talking
about the Constitution this the
Constitution that this is
unconstitutional it's our constitution
right it's Second Amendment literally he
is saying that the Second Amendment does
not exist because it your rights do not
come
from the Constitution the form of
government it's just doesn't or also the
fact that you know you've got this
constitution you've got these founding
fathers you've got your Bill of Rights
all these things
in which we have a or at least uh we
used to have a separation of church and
state and now Ron DeSantis is saying uh
what state right right that he's
literally like all Church no State you
know that's why I mean I mean they want
a theocracy that's the only way that
they can um you know also how does God
choose those if God truly did choose the
rights for us
it would be in many ways aligned with
the constitution in that you know we are
we are aspiring to to be equal amongst
our peers we want to give everyone equal
rights opportunities The Pursuit of
Happiness Liberty these are all things
that I would assume that God would
probably want
however Republicans don't really believe
so even though God said or you know even
though Republicans say God makes those
rights or Ron DeSantis says God makes
the rights we should be listening to him
and not this right you would you would
think that Christian values or or
Catholic values would teach you to love
thy neighbor don't commit adultery is he
Catholic is that why you say that no I
just say because Oh I thought I thought
maybe Rhonda says here's the thing
what's funny to me about that clip the
funniest part about it all is why are
you running for governor then right
government of a state government yeah
why why are you doing that if government
is so bad and it doesn't Grant you
rights it's almost like Ronda Santa
should be voted out because he all has
the man brains of this guy here's more
[ __ ] man brains of people who can't
even [ __ ] realize that women can piss
when they got a tampon in here's
Herschel Walker with some dumb [ __ ]
obviously because he's speaking watch
you don't cool
what do you see oh God as some of the
more man brains here here's another
doctor who's supposed to know [ __ ] that
doesn't know [ __ ] but let's listen Ben
Carson's gonna ask Herschel Walker here
the Heisman Trophy winner a really
pressing question and listen to the
answer this is this is important stuff
folks we're gonna about we're about to
vote tomorrow on if this guy's gonna be
United States enter so pay attention
really close if you haven't made your
decision already big biggest problems
going on in our country today
I think some of the biggest problems
going on in our country today we have so
many celebrities telling people that
they can't do it
telling a lot of people oh you know it's
you can't do it like you got to feel bad
for yourself feel sorry for yourself
we're just sad to mean
you know they've done it but they
telling you you can't do it and it's
like God you did it why they can't do it
I think that tell all the kids that uh
that you know they can't do it or until
I make it our kids feel sorry for
themselves and uh not having it we don't
want to educate
what in the [ __ ] is he talking about
I have no idea I have celebrities tell
people they can't I don't know what what
the hell does that even mean why is that
what the [ __ ] kind of I mean just the
mashed potato brains on this guy is
ridiculous it's this guy makes the guys
in the tampon videos look like Geniuses
look like geniuses
it's uh well first off I have not I have
not seen this video so as soon as Ben
Carson came on screen I was like oh [ __ ]
everything's pretty I mean like it was
already out the window as soon as I saw
her did you notice though Ben Carson was
even like what in the [ __ ] is he talking
about like he was like what the [ __ ] the
thing is you've got Ben Carson who you
know the joke is always made Ben Carson
doesn't know where he is or he feels
like he just woke up and kind of just
like walked into a room and he's like
where'd everybody go right Ben Carson
somehow neurosurgeon I don't know what
the [ __ ] happened Hey listen sometimes
you're just really really really good at
one thing right well I mean I guess you
know Trump and Republicans thought he
would be good at another thing where he
became you know the the head of Housing
and Urban Development and that has a lot
to do with neurosurgery by the way I
mean there's a total big cross over
there
it's totally a thing don't question it
you shouldn't question it because then
you've also got it if anyone remembers
you've also got when Katie Porter
brought out the Whiteboard and was
talking to Ben Carson and was like hey
what about reos
and he was like what and he's like oh
yeah he's like Oreos and it's like no
Oreos like real state-owned not Oreos
the the cookie with the cream in the
middle not that he had tampon brains
that that's yeah I'm gonna call from now
on here we have I you know what maybe
we'll even make a goddamn piece of merch
tampon brains I'm with tampon brains
with an arrow maybe maybe or maybe it's
just like a brain with like a tampon
string maybe that could be he's got
tampon brains he's got tampon brains
he's got tampon braids I want to show
you I don't know if you've seen this ad
this is a new Herschel Walker ad
um like the real one well let's let's
find out
ha I am Herschel
um Walker and I am running for a
campaign
I was just a little baby boy born here
in Georgia and when I was a little baby
I I was a little boy
I believe that God made a women's uh
women and and a man's is a man a man
can't have a baby out his butthole
I played football in the NFL I am also a
sheriff cop police officer and I got my
training on uh call up a duty if you
want your kids to learn the ABCs and not
the LGBT series
uh Walker
oh correct Herschel Walker isn't really
sure if he approved this message or not
but he signed the waiver anyway
[Laughter]
they're giving they're giving Hershey
Walker way too much credit in that video
yeah no really I mean oh that was too
good way too much credit way too much
credit it was
um that was pretty good have you seen uh
Dan Harmon's um last
um you know like his closing argument
for voting Democrat have you seen this
no he was on stage I don't know where
Dan Harmon he goes to he goes to a bar
all the time around the corner does he
really now I think I think this was um
I'm not sure where this was um but it's
some kind of event but he um he actually
um he was up talking in front of a crowd
and he he gave the per what I thought
was the perfect closing argument for the
2022 midterms I want to play it here
minority we can beat them we have to say
I'm not a Nazi though
two-thirds of the country just don't
want to be political it's not politics
just say you're not a Nazi
it's like taking a [ __ ]
you just do it
are you explode
you die if you don't [ __ ] and you die if
you don't say you're not a Nazi
[Applause]
fascism is a [ __ ] cancer it will eat
your country unless your country kills
it here's what happens when you get
cancer nothing good nothing there is no
way out of it I'm your country's doctor
you've got cancer you have fascism you
are going to suffer you are going to
fight you are going to feel pain you are
not getting out of this we have fascism
it is happening we're [ __ ] dead maybe
or
or maybe they're dead
that's about it
it's not a Continuum there's no gray
area it's not a fad fascism doesn't pop
up and then recede when it finds out no
one's into it
it doesn't respond to love it doesn't
respond to hate it doesn't respond to
ignoring it it doesn't respond to
timeouts it doesn't respond to attention
it doesn't respond to lack of attention
you stab it you cut it out you bombard
it with poison or you die and in any
case you will probably die don't die
talking to cancer
don't die hanging out with it don't die
arguing with it on Twitter
it's [ __ ] fascism enough
team up stop bitching about Bernie
Sanders I don't care what flavor you
want your democracy to be it's democracy
versus [ __ ] fascism
I think that's a perfect closing
argument like that is and and if it gave
here says show his crowd he obviously
has no idea who this person is he does
not know okay uh anyone seen Community
the show yeah anyone seen uh Rick and
Morty okay those are just two examples
of Dan Harmon's very hilarious brain
this is I don't I'm trying to I'm trying
to see where the venue is just to right
what what what what what uh fake Abe
doesn't understand is Dan Harmon isn't
running for anything he's just he's just
just a citizen he's a person who has a
microphone and he's a person who
believes in that microphone should be
used for good not for bad so that's why
he's doing it a lot and also that's this
is his podcast right this is harm in
town this is his podcast show that he
has he doesn't live right and he does it
live that's why I wasn't sure where it
was I I want to believe that that
someone was saying that this was
recorded in New York but I'm not sure
that that's why I don't know I mean like
here's the thing like whether you're in
LA or you're in New York right you know
if fake games show the crowd one it's
just it's a comedy venue or a theater
that he went to it's not a rally
okay he has a podcast
and then the topic of fascism because
the state of our country and in the
state of democracy is literally on the
ballot and he decided to use his
platform his show
to speak out against it and talk about
how we literally have this cancer I mean
the same way the same way I would
compare like election deniers to uh to
parasites and like our democracy in the
state of our country is an ant colony if
you don't remove them
from
prove what if you don't remove a
parasite from an ant colony it will
infect the rest of the colony and
democracy as we know it is is [ __ ]
gone and is he the reason why Rick and
Morty becoming you're funny dude dude
the reason why he it is him it's him
it's his [ __ ] it's his art you dumb
[ __ ] so he gets to do with it
what he wants that's why Rick and Morty
seems woke to you because it offends
your little sensitive snowflake ass
and it's his art he gets to say whatever
he wants you people who say you're for
[ __ ] free speech which we're going to
talk about on the Kathy Griffin Elon
Musk I want to talk about that but uh
before that ends get rid of vacate [ __ ]
him um I want to talk I want to show
fake Gabe his cult here this is crazy
everyone did you you sent me um is that
the Herschel Walker clip that you sent
me about that yeah yeah okay we'll play
that here in a second everyone's one
everyone calm down in the chat I'm gonna
play the Herschel Walker uh Marvin the
Martian
um
clip yeah it's Hershel Walker as Marvin
the Martian I'm going to show it to you
um
it's not very long I want to show you
this clip first though this I want to
give a disclosure here this is a cult
how many believe we're gonna have a
victory on Tuesday
so come on let's give a victory shot
let's strike the ground and let's give a
victory Shout
on the count of three are you ready so
here we go get your arrows out just go
strike
strike
strike come on keep going strike come on
strike come on strike the ground
right right come on come on
[Music]
let's try
try come on
definitely definitely not a cult yeah in
any way normally normally they're like
like you know in past Christians you
know they'd be like striking out World
hungry strike strike strike but they're
like go let's make sure fascist and
authoritarians take over let's make sure
that people don't have voices you know
what that actually reminds me of the
Striking that the draft yeah no who was
the um
uh let's see Donald Trump uh
uh Pastor oh yeah the crazy lady yeah
the woman the the Trump Evangelical
spiritual advisor Paula Paula White
Paula Michelle White let's see if you
can grab a clip of her because there's
one where she like
blah blah blah like literally that's
what she sounds like
um while I pull up this Herschel Walker
clip for everyone to see because it's
not very long I'm gonna show it it's um
it's actually a really good one I forgot
about this one until someone is
mentioning it uh
and it's taking forever okay so this is
uh Nikki Haley on the stage with him now
um Nikki Haley also said I guess that
that Warnock should be deported I'm not
sure why she thinks Warnock should be
deported he was born in Georgia so I
don't know why it's like people who tell
me I should go back or yeah but God's
country or I should Deport me I'm like
what the [ __ ] I was born in this country
well right but he's a sitting United
States senator from Georgia representing
Georgia like like I understand that some
people don't actually know exactly who
you are but they should at least be able
to know who a sitting United States
Senator especially Nikki Haley do you
think Nikki Haley knows that you are
actually we proved last night that the
Trump the Trump team knows who you are
oh me yeah you oh yeah yeah yeah yeah we
proved
um because we didn't know this we were
we were perusing around trying to find a
fake um
um Trump's statement that that you had
made about DeSantis right
um and everyone bought it hook line
Sinker online and they were pissed off
oh man they were pissed off Daniel Dale
was pissed off Seth aberson was [ __ ]
Evenson the man who you know I teach
parody I teach satire and then attack he
did he did like a three-hour live on
Instagram on the damn on the damn thing
he's the uh look I think Elon Musk and
Seth Amerson are the same person are
they really well not like they're
literally the same person but I believe
they are similar in their ways like they
can't take a joke and when they are the
butt of the joke or they don't
understand it then everyone else is the
meanie meanie pants uh bully and then
they block them people are mean though
gay people are mean they're mean but but
um the funny part about it is that uh
because Trump called DeSantis what do
you call him the sanctimonious
yeah it's kind of a lame [ __ ]
nickname there's better there's better
nicknames out there but um but he he got
a lot of flack for it but we went back
and you went back and you found that uh
thing because what did you say in that
statement it was uh I called him gutless
that's right it was gutless Ron DeSantis
that's right because we were because
when when that happened we were trying
to figure out a way to make sure people
didn't know or knew that it was that
somehow this had to be right because
that was at a time where
um Ron DeSantis and Trump were really
doing jacking each other off like
directions oh yeah yeah they were like
you did a great job no you did a great
job right right right right so so we put
that in there because I think even like
when when you were writing it you sent
it and I was like well it has to you
know go against the santus here and then
it'll kind of make it obvious that it's
not it's satire it's not parody but here
we are here we are again we always say
you CA you can't pair that was July we
are five months July 6 I think is when I
sent that right tweet and here we are
five months later or four months later
and uh uh
you know truth truth truth in comedy you
know like that's right it's just you
can't make this [ __ ] up they can't well
and the reason why we're saying this is
because I'm asking Gabe if Nikki Haley
knows who he is but the Trump team does
because there was Twitter had put a a
tag on it right right a a fact check on
it that you had not noticed before and
it even said in there that someone a
journalist I forget who checked with the
Trump team to make sure it was fake
that's the third time they've done this
because when I've been fact checked on
Reuters or I've been fact checked on uh
through Daniel Dale or I've been checked
for these fake for these fake yeah and
there have been there have been three
statements that I've done where it has
caught on this last one obviously was
like went crazy but I've had two
previous ones where somebody was like oh
and then they contact Liz Harrington and
they're like we didn't send that out so
they know
that I have been out there and I've been
making these things and they get it's
enough where it's not just once it's not
just twice but they've been contacted
three times to verify if this is
actually real or not
should we [ __ ] should we [ __ ] all over
him running for president I mean it'd be
really hard I guess we'd have to come up
with the truth because that's what it
was it was a true social post it was
yeah we put it in it's like a screenshot
so then it looked like it was from the
app and then Seth aberson was really
pissed off because
um he took it he took it did not even
check it right journalist he he got
pissed off at at the show too because we
made two different versions the the the
white screenshot and the dark screenshot
and we posted them uh one on our page
and one on yours so people would buy it
quicker and Seth averson did exactly
what we wanted he bought it Hook Line
singer he got all pissed off and he
actually perpetuated the statement more
than anything like he hasn't accounted
like a million followers and he did a
three-hour Instagram live to talk about
this statement the point that I'm trying
to make here is not that at all the
point I'm trying to make here is Nikki
Haley does not know who Gabe is I don't
know maybe she does maybe she does she
might who knows in the future it's
possible and she would definitely tell
you to probably be deported don't you
think oh 100 and also and keep in mind
the reason that Herschel Walker uh
you know he's I I don't know who else is
campaigning for him but you've got Scott
you've got uh Rick Scott you've got Tom
Khan Nikki hey like they're Ted Cruz Ted
Cruz game Lindsey Graham was talking for
him he was he was uh and it's the reason
they care so much is because obviously
if you have you're gonna have anyone
stump for you that's a bigger name or
has more kind of oomph to their uh to
their clout or whatever but this is one
guy who he's literally had a like
basically a starting lineup equal of
people that that have spoken for him or
spoken on his behalf
um because they're afraid that this seat
is going to continue to be held by uh
Raphael Warnock and they're afraid and
they want it because obviously right now
we're 50 50 split Democrat Republican
though you could argue that two of those
seats are more Republican than Democrat
but
they value this so much that they're
willing to go and
uh and and and just campaign or or speak
for him right and speak at him like uh
like Lindsay Walker did well here's
sorry Lindsay Lindsey Graham sorry mixed
up the two well it happens that way you
know I I have a question about this uh
why it's on pause is I don't understand
why they're not using the picture of him
holding up the badge that seems you
might as well double down I mean he did
it during the show like during the the
debate and then he didn't even interview
his interview he would just and then he
would go out on stage during his stump
speech and he would whip out the fake
Toys R Us badge let's listen to what he
has to say though about illegal aliens
I'm not [ __ ] you this is real I
wouldn't [ __ ] you you're my favorite
turd but this is real
if you're a martian you live in the
United States of America I'm going to
protect you too because you've blown to
my family if you're a martian you live
in the United States of America I'm
going to protect you too because you've
blown to my family if you're a martian
you live I know I'm playing over but it
takes a minute it takes a minute to
understand what he's saying he literally
he's not saying Martin like a guy named
Martin right he's saying Martian as in
like a fictional character on cartoons
that are from Mars right right do you
think like he's some somehow nobody
briefed him that you know aliens
and illegal aliens are not the same
right
do you do you think Heath believes that
his badge is real and that when someone
says illegal aliens he thinks they're
from outer space I think Herschel Walker
believes that he is oh man now I gotta
now I gotta make this I don't wanna I'm
afraid to make the joke because I'm
afraid someone's gonna take it right now
but basically I think Herschel Walker
thinks that he's a he's a Men In Black I
think that's what he thinks he is oh I
think that you gotta go tweet it tweet
it right now tweet it so no one steals
it and then make a graphic leader
um okay so what else were we gonna watch
now that I'm [ __ ] just
absolutely
the woman oh yeah did you again strike
and strike and strike and start I sent
you the club yeah okay okay
um yeah
this lady so uh back to the uh the
people at the uh the cult the cult
service or whatever that whatever that
[ __ ] is
um this is um
Paula what was her last name again Paula
White Paula Q Anon white right let me
know
now she makes this clip makes its
entrance into the Hulu movie called God
forbid have you watched that movie I
have not watched it yet I need to okay
now so I don't want to I don't I I would
encourage everyone to go watch it and we
are actually working on getting Billy uh
who made the film on the show but um uh
we're hoping we can get him on the show
he's really busy because this thing is
blowing up but in imagine this game
because it doesn't give away the movie
but in the movie
the main character the pool boy everyone
has heard the Jerry well Jerry Falwell
junior pool boy and his wife's Story the
pool boy met this Paula White and he
says she is nothing off stage like she
is on stage because it's all a [ __ ]
act but watch the ACT here watch the act
and strike and strike and strike and
strike and strike and strike
and strike until you have victory for
every enemy that is aligned against you
let there be that we would strike the
ground for you will give us Victory God
I hear a sound of abundance of rain I
hear a sound of Victory I hear a sound
of shouting and singing I hear a sound
of Victory I hear a sound this is like a
really really bad hip-hop song yeah I
mean it's what the [ __ ] is this
this is this is the same [ __ ] they were
doing in that other video isn't it
yep it's the strike I mean what does
that mean is there like I don't know the
Bible that well is there something in
the Bible where they strike the ground
or some [ __ ] does anyone know um let me
see because I don't know if you're like
oh I'm gonna strike you down like it's
always like the omnipotent God is like
gonna smoke you or whatever and right I
strike them down and they cannot raise
oh yeah I mean like I don't know I guess
there's there's several but they're
saying strike the gram let's strike
someone that I don't understand this I
don't get what they're saying okay let's
let's let's just I mean I don't know I'm
assuming that they're talking about
striking some sort of enemy down you
know this is the person that was
standing in the White House praying over
Trump by the way yeah yeah for people
who don't know this [ __ ] was in
the White House in our White House
praying over the president United States
as if it was it's crazy [ __ ] but keep
keep watching abundance of rain I hear a
sound of Victory I I hear a sound of an
abundance of rain I hear a sound of
Victory the Lord says it is done do you
like the guy behind well he's like oh
Jesus Christ look at him he's like she's
like I'm going he's I got my robe I've
got I'm just practicing my lines right
now
maybe maybe he's maybe he's you know
what maybe they're doing so I forget
what time of year this was was this was
this after the election is this
Christmas time maybe I'm trying to
remember like is this guy like the 4 P.M
Jesus at their sermon oh so he's he's
practicing his lines or something but
the guy's just just nonchalant walking
behind her like it's like a cafe or
something keep watching it's done the
Lord says it is done the Lord says it is
done for I hear victory victory victory
victory in the corners of Heaven in the
corner there's got to be a song There Is
there's a remix Hold on oh I didn't pull
that up look here's the guy again here
he is again look he comes the opposite
direction
what the [ __ ] is that
I guess I guess they're like no no no no
no you're the 4 pm Jesus get back over
on the other side we've got we've got
the 3 pm Jesus here you've got to go
back over there so he's like oh I'm
really sorry I'll go practice my lines
over here yeah he's like oh no not over
there all right here's a remix that I
yeah earlier there's got to be something
much better here than this than the
actual video here let's there's another
one too with a cat in it oh really oh
yeah even better let's yeah but you play
that one and then I'll see if I can okay
let's see if we can okay so this is the
Paula White remix
we're probably going to get knocked for
a sound ear because it's probably actual
music ah [ __ ] it let's watch it strike
and strike and strike and strike until
you have victory for every enemy that is
aligned against you let there be then we
would strike the ground for you will
give us victory
[Music]
I hear a sound of victories
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was that was fantastic oh
they're they really are pretty good at
this I don't know I think I think there
might be a career ahead of them uh
Kenneth Copeland was in that video he
appeared over the weekend too did you
know did he I didn't see that yeah he he
made an appearance at a rally with Trump
um of course
and said something oh man Evangelical
Christians evangelicals they're [ __ ]
crazy man they're insane they they are
they gripped you out of money they get
multiple I mean like Kenneth Copeland
he's like oh how many how many g5s I
need I need as many as I can get where I
can like I can only I can only uh I
can't uh I can't fly I can't fly coach I
can't even fly first class I need to be
in my own plane so I'm closer to God and
I can pray to him oh here here he is
here he is listen to what he says about
being a Christian nationalist this is
real here's Kenneth Copeland this is
over the weekend
um this is in Pennsylvania is the what
the placard says as you can see the
Cheeto dust q and honor standing there
behind him he's not jacking off giraffes
at this point but he was standing behind
him let's watch
there are things
this great state of Pennsylvania
Liberty was born here
I've been accused of being a Christian
nationalist
I wonder why that is why would he be
accused of being a Christian nationalist
yeah kind of funny I don't know let's
see let's see what his rationale is here
our first president
1789
opened his Bible at 17th chapter of
Genesis
where God made Covenant with Abraham
and he read that
how does this what does this have to do
with Kenneth Copeland being a Christian
nationalist I'm I'm not following yet
I'm still not following what what does
this have to do I don't know I mean it's
just trying to prove that Christian
nationalism is a good thing here that
Nazis are good is that what he's trying
to do I don't understand uh and he's
like it's just George Washington was a
Nazi too damn it I don't know let's
let's keep listening
and he bowed his knee
and he prayed
and he said
you'll be our God
so Donald Trump's standing back there
too I want to point this out he has no
[ __ ] clue why can't the government's
talking about number one Donald Trump
probably doesn't even know who the first
president was he has no idea about this
about this verse in the Bible for sure
100 no [ __ ] clue no way he knows that
I mean he doesn't he doesn't know the
verse of the Bible he doesn't know the
words of the national anthem he doesn't
know anything he just Smiles no no he
knows how to jack off those giraffes
yeah okay fine he's yeah
he can definitely jack off those
giraffes like nobody else like he look
he knows he knows a lot of people are
saying a lot of people are saying he's
the best at jerking off giraffes that's
true that he's as many people are saying
many people are saying the best and we
are saying that we've heard people say
it so okay let's see if let's see if
Kenneth Copeland makes any sense here at
all about Christian Nash the guy looks
also
I know this is just a C-SPAN feed which
is never really that great
um why why does their speed suck so bad
they shoot this [ __ ] in like 1080p right
yeah but it's just the way that it
converts but in this in I mean like
Kenneth Copeland looks like the goddamn
devil but in this he looks like he's a
[ __ ] undead zombie like he looks like
he just came out of the crypt and he's
like vote for Donald and the rest of the
Republicans forever and ever and ever
Robert Seagate that's the problem with
this setup with this plane see with
their new setup with the plane that's
why these these these videos are going
to look like this because they have all
the lights on the plane to show his
plane because he wants everyone to see
his plane the problem is if they light
them it will drown it will drown the
plane out right yeah so they can't and
what I mean by is for video effect
because they're shooting this with their
own cameras to run ads and [ __ ] they're
already folks listen to me they've got
professional people on the ground gonna
make this look like Hitler 2.0 when he
it when and if he does announce to run
he's gonna have this big video it's
going to be this big reel from these
rallies and him walking off the this
this Trump farce one it's all part of
the plan and that's why this looks like
[ __ ] on the C-SPAN feed is because the
lighting isn't for [ __ ] Kenneth
Copeland and Donald Trump In This Moment
the lighting is for their cameras to
show that the big Trump Trump's plane is
in the background but let's see if
Kenneth Copeland puts together a
collective thought here and will be your
people
would you call him a Christian
nationalist
he was a Christian Patriot
Hallelujah
so
by Covenant this nation belongs to God
therefore voting is a sacred Trust
and if you don't vote
hush
for at least two years you have no
comment
I don't know Donald Trump is getting
really nervous in the background by the
way
one can go up on the scenes what does
this have to do with him being a
Christian nationalist I didn't put any
of that together I I don't know I mean
he is a Christian the thing is at the
end of the day you put these guys on you
put these grifters on stage and all they
know how to do is not help you is not be
able to relate or understand your
position you've got these Elite because
that's what they are you have these
elitist people you know one of them owns
one plane the other guy speaking Kenneth
Copeland owns [ __ ] five planes or
some number now uh Because he believes
that and I just I here's a video what's
his videos I've seen this before yeah so
this is Inside Edition and they
approached Kenneth Copeland on the
runway tarmac after he gets off his
plane to basically say why don't you
like to fly coach and he gives the most
insane answer about uh
why why God wants him to fly in a
private plane why he needs a private
plane why he needs more than one private
plane why he needs all this money again
anyone who is a is an Evangelical or
Christian that is taking money from
these like mega churches do not actually
follow the word of God or follow Christ
well does anyone I mean besides the
[ __ ] delusional believe that let's
listen to what his answer is here don't
want to fly commercial why have you said
that you won't fly commercial you said
that it's like getting into a tube with
a bunch of demons why do you think that
no no listen to me just saying okay
getting into a plane with Kenneth
Copeland would be like getting into it
for everyone else you are putting right
right you are ruining their experience
exactly I am all for again the global
never flying or flying in a private
plane by the way do not want him around
other you know decent human beings that
could go right but let's listen
not the people
the main reason
is because of the need
if if I flew commercial
I'd have to stop 65 of what I'm doing
that's rid of me isn't it true that you
want to fly commercials so that you can
fly in luxury how much money did you pay
for Tyler Perry's Gulfstream jet for
example well for example that's really
none of your business but it's not the
business of your donors
I paid got them
he's like oh [ __ ] that's a great Point
like you're you're making really good
arguments here and that is destroying me
be transparent with my donors on how I
spend their money
oh this is you're really I can't come up
with I should just not talk into a
microphone probably is what right is
what he should probably not do but let's
listen because I'm sure he I'm sure he
comes up with a great argument here I'm
sure of it
you kind of caught me off guard here
okay
now here I'd like to give you a chance
to to catch your breath and and have a
conversation we don't want to we don't
want to catch you off guard I Love
Inside Edition you got to get this now
hey you listening to me my wife thinks
inside
there you go just can't answer the
question
but look at the look at the face
I'm telling you he's the goddamn devil
let's keep going let's see what else
appears here that Edition is oh yeah
now
thank you Lord help me just let me let
me pray
we have brought over a hundred let's see
this the latest figures okay I can't
take it anymore I can't I can't take it
anymore I just I can't do it anyway the
tldr of this video right is that he's a
[ __ ] boxer yeah he's a terrible human
being that thinks that he's better than
other people uses the money that they
donate to the parish and the church and
the mecca church that he's a part of for
his own luxurious travel and expenses
and lifestyle and he's got thousand
dollar suits and nice little cufflings
and ties and all this stuff he's got
private security at the end of the day
that is not that is not
how how
Jesus how Christ how God would want you
to follow right they would want to make
sure hey look all this money that you're
giving to this church one maybe just
keep it for yourself two
if you do give it to us then maybe we
help out others in the community who are
not as fortunate we have programs we
have yes money is their God it is 100
their God Kent says on YouTube money is
their God it that's that's right well
and here's the thing because I know we
were going to get to speaking of money
and God to Elon and Kathy Griffin but
we're probably gonna have to hold it for
Wednesday and surely there'll be more in
that Saga foreign and the reason why is
because tomorrow is is Tuesday
and more importantly it's election day
so we are going to be talking about
elections tomorrow I'm sure Texas Paul
is going to be joining us
um I have a special I know it's election
day the only the only kind of veering I
want to do is a special Taco that I
found on the internet that I want to
make sure I get your in Texas we talked
about spam a couple weeks ago oh God I
know what you're going to do yeah so I
wanna I wanna make sure that we so
that's the only detour I want to take
from the election tomorrow but folks
listen this this clip from Kenneth
Copeland at the end where he's he's
subverting you know just a simple
question yeah and and giving an answer
to a question just like he was trying to
make something into a Bible verse about
how he is or isn't a Christian
nationalist that is who the Republicans
are listening to if you want that to
have influence into your government and
your life and your policy fine that is
your right but if you don't which I'm
sure you do not go vote for Democrats go
vote [ __ ] blue but anything more than
anything just vote go vote and encourage
three people to vote tomorrow is the day
we are down to the skinny here there's
there's only a few hours left for you to
put together your plan and make sure
three other people have their plan
together and they make sure three people
have their plan so encourage people to
vote and when you find those three find
three more keep encouraging keep leaning
into your democracy we're going to do
this I am very confident the the early
numbers are good [ __ ] the polls they're
all [ __ ] up [ __ ] Nate silver and [ __ ]
Elon Musk they have no [ __ ] clue what
they're talking about it is you it is
you that are activated as you that are
engaged you can do this we can save our
democracy
Gabe until tomorrow same time same exact
place it's election day tomorrow don't
[ __ ] miss it Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon